[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report app presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory alongside the
lovely live moods live it's the holiday
season are you excited for this week of
nba basketball
i am i'm excited to give out picks it's
the season of giving and charles barkley
and fanduel are also in the giving
spirit as well they've teamed up to give
away over seven million dollars in gifts
to fanduel customers through december
27th so get on fanduel and look for odds
boosts same game parlays specials and
more it's the season of giving so let's
cash out head to the fandle sportsbook
it is the season of giving we're always
in the giving mood here liv we are
always in the giving mood but in the
holiday spirit we're giving away
locks we're giving away hoodies and
we're giving away jerseys today so
please get in the comments i need gifts
i need emojis but most importantly guys
i need winners only please go ahead type
it out if you guys want actually the
producer just whispered into my ear greg
give away a hoodie so i'm in the
comments i am in the comments right now
liv giving away hoodies i see be our bet
in the comments shout out to you guys
all right here we go
jacob kearns jacob curtin says take two
things tonight he says takes the lakers
or the oh he says two things lakers or
math i don't know if you're telling us
to take either or brother but guess what
doesn't matter you are walking away with
the hoodie all right liz it is tuesday
it's tnt tuesday fans bullets fanduel is
boosting the 3x2 in both games making it
three by tuesday the question is will
there be two three-pointers in the first
three minutes
of the game the three by two cash yes it
cashed last week in the warriors knicks
game just like me and liv told y'all we
told you i would let's take a look there
it is you guys know who this is i call
him 30. there it is from the top that
was the tie right there that was the tie
and then we got the former warrior right
here alex burke from the wing
yes
sir
yes sir the three by two cashed easily
last week and today we asked you on
twitter
which three by two will cash tonight
will it be the pacers taking on the heat
or will it be the sun's taking on the
lakers here are the current results
wow that that that was impressive i mean
the phoenix suns and the lakers is uh
winning this one by a landslide i would
say uh lyft both three by twos are in
plus money which one do you like the
best i personally like fading the public
on this one which is either a good thing
or a bad thing depending on the night
but i kind of like riding with the
pacers and the heat in this one
both phoenix and the lakers guard the
three better than both the pacers and
the heat the heat allowed the third most
threes and although they're missing
quite a few guys tonight they still have
duncan robinson and kyle lowry who would
have cashed this three by two in the
last game against the pacers because
they each had a three before that first
three minutes was up so i actually like
fading the public here but i'd love to
know how you feel about it
yes we always have interesting stacks
interesting takes when it's regarding
the three by two because it's an
interesting bed it's two threes in the
first three minutes it's very unique uh
liv let's see what the people are riding
with i am in the comments i got be our
bed in the comments they said sons
lakers they are fading you live
unfortunately uh landon is also going
with the sun's light well they're not
fading you because we're riding both
three by twos you know what i mean like
they're just leaning the other way so
there's no fading going on here shout
out to landon shout out to br bedding uh
i got one more and me one more enemy
kirk says the sun's
is a lock into heroin so sons lakers is
a lot to hammer so it's apparent it is
apparent we are all riding the suns and
the lakers three by two believe don't
feel
no type of ways don't feel no no type of
animosity or anything no hard feelings
because we are also riding with indiana
in the miami heat of 3x2 why not
sprinkle on both all right
we want your player
point picks for
the suns and the lakers game get so get
in the comments and tell us what you
guys think let's take a look at the
current odds live
what do you like here
so i'm actually liking two plays i am
really liking jay crowder over nine and
a half points tonight he has 13 points
the last time these two teams met the
lakers also allowed the fourth most
points to that power forward position an
average of 22 and a half and crowder has
hit this over in six of the last eight i
also like russell westbrook over 19 and
a half points tonight he scored 15 the
last time he played phoenix and there's
no a.d tonight so i think westbrook has
a lot more opportunities to get some
buckets here the suns also give up an
average of 23 points to the opposing
point guard so i like westbrook to have
a night
liv likes russ to have a night live and
uh i think i'm gonna piggy back with you
simply because you mentioned there's no
a.d so we all know what brody likes to
do when he has to be the guy he usually
steps up to the plate and becomes
aggressive so i think he's going to be
real aggressive tonight scoring the ball
and passing the ball so i'm going to go
with brody over
19 and a half points we're going to lock
that one in i'm in the comments i want
to see what you guys are talking about
uh
cyrus sarah johnson said watch out for
monk watch out for monk on the lakers
okay
like the curveball there uh wes miller
says give him
book and jay whippy over uh d book and
my man jay crowder uh he's rocking with
you liv so shout out to you
wes and cyra i got one more i got one
more in me carlos moo says
has crotter over nine points and d book
of course so he's rocking with crowder
he's rocking with d book shout out to
everybody that i mentioned you guys are
walking away with hoodies live it's my
favorite part of the show let's talk
major markets money lines against the
spreads and
point totals for tonight's game let's
take a look at the odds liv
what are you seeing here and what do you
like
yeah i like over 224 and a half in that
phoenix
lakers game these are two top these are
two teams with top five pace offensively
both of these teams ranked top 10 in
points scored per game defensively the
lakers ranked bottom five in points
allowed per game so i like this to be a
high scoring affair and if we are riding
that three by two on this three by
tuesday then it's going to be a high
score because we're gonna cash that in
the first three minutes lots of three
balls going up and swishing in the net
so i like this to be a high scoring
affair i'm taking over 224 and a half
liv is rocking with the over in that
game i like that liv i actually like
that because i do see this one being a
high scoring affair russell westbrook is
going to be uh leading the warriors
tonight and you know russ likes to get
up and down the court uh
let me give away some hoodies let me
give away some hoodies because i want to
see what the people is riding with
before i give my pic liv oh b.r bedding
is in the comments saying liv is a sharp
shout out to br betting uh marquan b
says sons minus six and
six and a half to the moon he's taking
that bet to the moon shout out to you
mark one you were walking away with a
hoodie uh kelly not uber he says
guarantee westbrook triple double live
that'll be good for you because i mean a
lot of points of russ is out there
scoring out their passing out their
rebounding uh so shout out to everybody
that i mentioned you all are walking
away with the hoodie but i'm gonna hop
in here
i'm gonna take a look at that indiana
miami heat game i'm gonna rock with the
indiana pacers money line
simply because the heat are short-handed
they have a lot of injuries they have a
lot of injuries to their team this uh
this season a lot of guys been jump uh
bouncing out like flies jumping out like
flies uh so i'm gonna rock with the
pacers and i'm gonna stay moneyline
because i think this was gonna be a
close one so let's play it safe take the
money line and uh let's keep it pushing
man let's keep it pushing all right we
talked major markets live now let's talk
player props it's time for lock or not
i'm gonna put up a prop i'm gonna put up
a prop and i need all of you and i mean
everybody in the comments
to tell me whether it is a lock or it is
not
liv i know you ready and i know the
people in the comments is ready so let's
just get right to it let's get right to
it first up we got my man lebron james
that's how the little kid said they like
to say to lebron james we got lebron
james
to have a double double tonight sitting
that plus 110 live do you think this is
a lock or do you think this is not a law
i think it's a lock and if you're
looking at it just from like a storyline
perspective no a.d uh the sun's handled
business against lakers earlier this
season and i know lebron doesn't want
that to happen again but from more of a
statistics standpoint he has hit a
double-double in three of the last five
he had 25 points five assists and two
rebounds the last time he played the
suns i think his best bet to hit a
double-double tonight is with points and
with boards and because a.d is out that
gives him a lot more opportunities to
get boards and he's facing a son's team
that ranks bottom 10 and rebounds aloud
to their opponent so i think points and
boards for him tonight he's hitting this
double double so i think it's a lock
lift thinks it's a lock i'm gonna follow
her i think this is a lot too but
instead of rebounds liv instead of
rebounds i want you guys to look at
the assist i want you guys to look at
this is
somebody mentioned somebody mentioned
liv
russ triple double but i want to talk
about the possibility of a lebron triple
double i love the rebounds lift but i
also think the assist is gonna be there
for lebron no ad we mentioned it it's
gonna be a high paced game you're
talking over lebron what does he do he
facilitates the rock i'm gonna go with a
lot here i'm gonna go with a lock here
but i want to see what you guys are
talking so i'm in the comments right now
i'm in the handy dandy ipad up i got a d
a d i x i x says lock city throw away
the king it's lebron he puts up numbers
no a d and lebron wants his revenge
tonight against the sons and his boy cp3
he's locking it in shout out to uad love
love the take up i got brady brady's
rocking with me he says uh
lebron james triple double in all caps
live lock so he's rocking with lebron
james to score a triple double uh and
landon landon floss is in the comments
saying he cannot agree with you more liv
he's riding with you so shout out to you
landon uh for riding with liv next up is
d book
next up is d book to score three or more
three pointers tonight liv this is also
plus money sitting at plus 124.
do you think this is a lock or do you
think this is not
i feel like the public and the comment
section is not gonna like what i have to
say but i don't think this is a lock i
mean he's this is only a second game
back he shot 33 from the three the last
time that he played the lakers the
lakers opponents actually have the sixth
lowest three point percentage so they
have pretty solid perimeter defense
again lebron james this is a revenge
game for him they are gonna buckle down
on guys like devin booker that they know
can shoot the ball and they don't want a
guy like d book to get hot because then
that means trouble for the lakers so i
like the defense to be tough on him
tonight i actually think this is not a
lock i don't feel comfortable with it
but
i'd love to know how you feel about it
liv uh
i'm gonna go the other way i'm gonna go
the other way for a couple of reasons we
mentioned we mentioned the fast pace we
mentioned fast pace up and down you like
the over i think that this will be a
fast paced game we know cle uh we know
the suns like to play up and down the
court and we know the lakers are gonna
have to run with no ad so i think this
is gonna be a fast paced game usually in
fast-paced games that mean more
three-pointers are attempted so i like
that trend and then i also want to talk
about his last game his first game back
he put up eight threes liv that's a lot
he put up eight threes he made four
so he's putting them up he's throwing
them up you can't be mad at if if i'm
betting somebody to make threes i want
them to chuck up three so you can't be
mad deep book might be chucking up some
threes so i'm gonna say this one is a
lock
and uh i'm in the comments now i'm in
the comments because i want to see if
you guys think that this is a lock or
not oh they are on your side i got kirk
o-l-l-o-s
says no not a lock with a lot of stop
sign emojis uh
i got
i got money merv money merv is in the
comments with a lot of x's not rocking
with it uh they're not rocking with deep
book man they they on your side live
they they rock it with you uh but
maybe crowded that's not crowder we'll
get those threes that's what i need for
the over on the point so crowder is the
three guy tonight
y'all heard that liv just dropped a
scoop for y'all he said crowder is the
three is that a lock or not you guys let
us know in the comments but finally we
have cp3
you guys know how i feel about cp3 we
call him the point god uh cp3
to record 10 or more assists today this
one's not plus money live it's sitting
at -130
do you like this one do you think this
is a lock or not
i do think it's a lot and i think that's
exactly why it's at -130 obviously the
value's not as great as the other plays
but i do love this play for cp3 i think
it's a lock like we've said devin booker
is back so chris paul can kind of take a
step back from that scoring role and
really focus on the facilitating he had
14 assists against the lakers in their
last meeting and the lakers are
currently allowing the sixth most assist
to their opponent so i like chris paul
cp3 to be in that facilitator role
tonight and i think he hits he hits 10
plus with no problems so i think it's a
lot
lift thinks it's a lot and uh liv i'm
right there with you i'm going the nail
i'm going to put the hammer on the nail
and just nail it in and drill it into
you guys head that this one is going to
be a high scoring affair and with that
you know with the high scoring affair
there's a lot of ball movement
and we know who the point guard is my
guy cp3 uh so i i see him going over 10
assists as well so i'm gonna lock that
in let me see what the people are saying
i got cj prince says cp3 lock for assist
the lakers defense is terrible i could
not agree with you more drea is in the
comments live drea says
easy lock easy lock shout out to
everybody that i mentioned you all are
walking away with hoodies uh
live i think it's the best time of the
show the time that everybody's been
waiting for it's time to build the br
betting custom parlay which you yes you
at home
can ride along with us on fanduel oh and
wow fanduel is doing something a little
special liv fanduel's doing something a
little special these days tell them
what's up
yeah fanduel is now giving you the
chance to win even bigger on your same
game parlays you can now combine
bets from multiple games into a same
game parlay plus that is the new new
name same game parlay plus so get on
fanduel be sure to check it out you know
that we are all about cashing out around
here so this is a perfect opportunity to
do that so head over to the fanduel
sportsbook and let's get it started
get it started in here yes let's get it
started uh but tonight tonight tonight
i'm building a same game parlay for
indiana versus miami and i need
everybody and i mean everybody to get in
the comments and tell me what they think
which legs are locked which legs are not
live
are you ready
i am ready i was born ready let's get
into it
liv's ready i'm ready y'all ready let's
jump right into it first leg of the
parlay we are talking about malcolm
brogdon here live malcolm brogdon to get
20 points tonight please please please
tell me you like this one
a little nervous about this leg i'm not
gonna lie to you just a little nervous
he's only averaging 16 points in two
games against the heat this season and
the heat right now allow the fewest out
of any team in the league they allow the
fewest points to the opposing point
guard position so
a little nervous for this one
but
if he lifts up and does his job and
takes advantage of a heat team that has
a lot of guys out he should be able to
hit it but i'm treading lightly
i like the butt you waited very very
late to drop the butt
and then you gave your tank i like that
i like that a lot uh duncan robinson
let's move on let's move on hopefully
this one can make you feel just a little
bit more comfortable live because we
want you to feel comfortable around here
when we're giving out these parlays we
got duncan robinson three plus three
pointers do you like this do you not
maybe so
yes no
[Music]
i do
um i do like this one and i'm going to
tell you why obviously he is a
three-point shooter with jimmy butler
and bam adubaya both out he's really had
to step up as a scorer on this team he's
had four threes in both games against
the pacers this year but i gotta be
honest i'm gonna be fully transparent
with you on this one robinson in the
bubble was a different breed of
basketball player from the three and we
haven't really seen that since so i get
a little bit nervous betting on him he's
been a little bit inconsistent for me i
have been burned a few times on duncan
robinson but realistically
this should hit this shouldn't have any
problems he's had four in both games
against this team and the heater out
some pretty important important guys
that like to score so he's gonna have to
hit this uh in order for the heat to
hang in this one but
i always sweat a little bit with
robinson just a little
no you you have a really really good
point because in the bubble they were
comparing duncan robinson to klay
thompson and uh
i haven't seen any klay thompson uh
comparisons lately but um
that they were comparing the two at one
time but
hopefully duncan can hit three for us
tonight because he's going to be getting
a lot of assist
a lot of assists from my guy who's up
next in the parlay kyle lowry live we're
going with kyle lowry to go
eight or or no eight or plus assists
do you like that one do are you rocking
with it you rock it with kyle yes no
i love this leg of the parlay i love it
he has had double-digit assists in the
last two games that he has played and
without jimmy butler and bam adebayo we
have really seen kyle lowry step into
that leadership facilitator role you can
tell that he's prioritizing scoring less
and less and really just being a
facilitator which seems to be working
for this heat team and he needs to
continue to do that tonight if they want
to hang in with this pacers team so i
love this play i think it is
using the l word scares me sometimes but
i do think it's a lock and he should hit
this without a
and problem doesn't like to use the l
word uh that's funny that that that's
funny i'm gonna try to get you to say it
more now simply because you told me that
you don't like to say it but uh let's
talk about this last leg of the parley
live because this one i really really
love i love this one a lot we're talking
about my god the montes some bonus
10 plus rebounds live come on give i
know you like this one
love this one like is not big enough of
a word i love this play anything with
sabonis and rebounds i really like and i
have made so much money betting his
props whether it be points plus rebounds
or just rebounds straight up i love this
play uh he's hit this and for the last
five he averages 14 rebounds in two
games against the heat this season
it shouldn't be a problem i love it
should not be a problem for my guy
damantes love the vibes from liv
now let's see
the ticket let's see the ticket let's
see what we will be making if we was to
put a hundred now we're gonna be walking
away with 483 i like that plus 483 uh
liv before i get into the comments what
are you grading the br betting parlay
let's give it a solid b minus you're
still passing the class i'm a little
nervous about brogden
uh robinson is hit or miss when he shows
up he shows up and when he doesn't it's
like he's sleepwalking sometimes but
i do like the legs they should hit kyle
lowry i love sabonis i love so i'm gonna
give it a b minus you're still passing
the class it's a good parlay and the
last time i gave a b-minus
it cashed so we're gonna rock with the
b-minus this time
yeah i mean we like we like to take you
out of your comfort zone liv put you
know take you out of your comfort zone
get you feeling a little just a little
bit uncomfortable and then last time we
did that you gave us a b minus we won so
i don't dislike this b minus i don't
dislike this b minus at all um
let me get into the comments because the
producer just whispered in my ear give
away a jersey so
guess what
i'm giving away a jersey and i see aj
beer 9 a.j beer 9 his name is often he
gave us a b plus
for the parlay he gave us a fire emoji
so guess what austin you are walking
away with the jersey of your choice
thank you for sticking around and thank
you for giving us the b-plus and the
fire emoji i'm back into the comments
live because i'm giving out hoodies now
i got
richie 21 is here and he says sabonis
lowry and robinson easy lock brogden
more risky but i think he hits it
tonight those are great vibes ricardo i
am giving you a hoodie i got one more
enemy lift i got one more g 26 i give it
a a minus only because brockton might
not get 20 points but i think three out
of the four will hit for sure
appreciate your good vibes we appreciate
your good vibes but brockton's gonna hit
brogden's gonna hit and we're gonna put
that into the atmosphere we're gonna
manifest that we're gonna
guys send me sunsets send me sunsets in
the comments we need good vibes um
yeah good vibes only gvo's a lot of
gvo's my guy mikey said it best a lot of
gvos uh but we asked you in the app guys
we asked you in the app who's your best
bet
to win it all
get in the comments and tell us what do
you think let's take a look at the
current odds
live
talk to the people talk to me what do
you like here
i got to tell you i am loving the nets
right now being a head of the warriors
it's giving the warriors better value
i'm still riding with the warriors to
take care of business and listen this
next team right now has too many
questionable variables right i mean
we've got kyrie irving in conversation
to join this team again i'm not sure how
that's gonna throw off the chemistry
we've already got a james harden that's
saying he doesn't know his role on
offense now you're gonna add another
ball hog to the mix and try to figure
out what offense looks like it terrifies
me so i'm loving that vegas likes the
nets right now in the lead because it's
giving us better value for golden state
so i would absolutely take the warriors
at plus 600 because i'm not sure the
value will be that good again so i'm
gonna grab it at plus 600. yeah
that's a great great point we know
clay's coming back we know wiseman's
coming back
uh
we don't know if this the odds are going
to stick at plus 600 i'm gonna hop into
the comments though because i want to
know
which way you guys are leaning uh liv
i'm in the comments
my guy lo so g ball
lo so says the bulls is taking it all
shout out to you loso uh you are walking
away with the hoodie big face coffee big
face coffee 20 says the miami heat jimmy
bam oladipo lowry hero tucker scary
hours
shout out to you jimmy you're also
walking away with the hoodie
liv
i see landon i gave landon the hoodie
earlier but landon is spamming us
because he keeps on putting gsw those i
mean gsw that stands for the golden
state warriors and i'm going to stop
right there giving away hoodies
everybody that i mentioned you're
walking away with a hoodie because
my guy landon mentioned the golden state
where's liv you mentioned the golden
state warriors and you guys at home know
that that's my pick but i want to focus
on
the nets here let's pull the graphic
back up because
i want to focus on the nets they're
sitting at plus
they're sitting at plus 260
and we don't even know if kyrie's coming
back liv you talked about chemistry you
talked about them playing with each
other james harden doesn't know his role
we kyrie's we don't know if he's going
to play home games or not
we don't even know if he's going to be
able to practice in new york or not like
just think about the playoffs think
about the playoffs the playoffs it get
real interesting they get real
down to the nitty-gritty and uh
chemistry is going to be
chemistry is going to be needed in order
to win in the playoffs
and the the nets they just have so many
questions around them they just have so
many questions around so it's hard for
me to lay
plus 260 on the team with so many
questions that's that's that that just
doesn't clicked in my head so something
that does click is the golden state
warriors sitting at plus 600 and we have
two starters two of them not one but two
starters coming back into the fold so uh
i like my chances with that plus 600
live
let me i already hopped into the
comments but i'ma hop back in there
because i just want to see what they're
talking about uh
yep they're rocking with the warriors i
got eight chunk two says sons though
eight shoes
uh go garden sands winners only go
garden also said trey kyrie uh
yeah uh ow al biski alby silk says
lakers dark hoes or dark horse don't
count out lebizzle he's still the king
don't sleep
uh
shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you guys are walking away with
a hoodie besides go garden he i heard
the producer just whispered into my ear
that he has 50 hoodies so unfortunately
go garden we cannot send you hoodie we
might sing you a jersey i don't know but
i think that's end that's the end of the
show liv uh it's time to get on up out
of here thank you guys for tapping into
the group chat presented by fanduel
remember what you learned today
the phoenix suns los angeles lakers 3x2
is a lock we are riding that get on
fanduel entail the br betting same game
parlay and bet your own
same game
parlay plus the dubs they're winning it
all me and liv we're on the same
wavelength with that we are also
dropping a special christmas episode
so check it out on christmas eve right
here in the br app if you want a hoodie
today we will dm you
alongside live moods i'm greg ivory me
and liv we leave in the group chat
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you